a grieving mother feeling closer to
getting justice after being awarded
millions in the wrongful death lawsuit
against republic services after her
child was hit and killed by a driver of
a truck this was back in 2017. victoria
saha joining us now live from where the
tragic accident happened with how the
jury came to its decision victoria
eleven-year-old jasmine espana was
trying to cross this intersection right
here in viking and sand hill at the same
time a driver of the republic services
garbage truck was also trying to
cross he failed to heal and ultimately
hit and killed jasmine but today the
jurors said that they were both at fault
jasmine's bon and carzione espana filed
a wrongful death suit against republic
services her attorney asked for 65
million dollars in damages after a
two-week trial and almost two days of
deliberation the jury awarded her 38.8
million dollars jurors found republic
services driver julio cortes solano to
be negligent in jasmine's death the
lawsuit claimed cortes solano had a
history of safety violations they also
found jasmine's partly to be blamed as
she entered the crosswalk without
looking republic services was found
negligent in hiring training and
retaining cortes solano jasmine's mother
says she forgives cortes solano and the
attorney says he hopes the company
learns from this
hopefully this verdict at least gets
their attention
and they know in the future they've got
to be better our city deserves better
our community deserves better
jasmine's mother says she will continue
to remember her daughter's smile as she
moves on
i reached out to republic services
regarding the verdict they sent a
statement saying quote we extend our
heartfelt condolences to the family and
friends of jasmine espana this was a
tragic accident republic services has
always maintained a strong culture
committed to safety and best in class
safety programs and will continue to do
so they said that they will reevaluate
their options right now but they
couldn't comment any further reporting
live victoria saha 8 news now